Hey Stephen, how's it going?
And so I'm just not bad.
Do you mind if I ask you 67 questions?
Sure. All right, let's do this.
What is the culture like at salesforce?
How the culture is great.
It's a real emphasis on research and uh,
really I guess advancing Ai.
What excites you the most
about machine learning?
Thinking.
So the capability for people to do stuff
that no one had really been able to do
before that,
like an entire workforce of people.
Okay.
Do you miss about where you grew up?
Okay. One thing about
Australia is eucalyptus leaves.
They are beautiful and they smell so nice.
Eucalyptus trees everywhere.
And Luckily we have a few of them in
California. What time do you wake up?
I wake up, uh, oh gosh. More like 10:00 AM
it was one of the most stressful but a
truly pleasurable experiences in my life.
I loved so much.
What website?
I would have to say Twitter is
my main vice. And also verse year
favorite machine learning
mixture of soft maxes.
One person. Who would it be? Uh,
Shannon from entropy.
Your last AI started Gacaca wired by
salesforce. How did you celebrate?
The whole team went out and had drinks
and one of the nearby bars so we're
pretty tight. So a normal, what's it
like doing research as a full time job?
As a full time job?
It's amazing cause you actually get to
hurt it on the exact problem that you're
interested in and just stay
there and keep working at it.
Bravest thing you've ever done.
Um Ooh.
Probably move to the u s but
away from friends and family.
What is one thing that scares you?
I would say heights.
Honestly. This is something that I don't
think I'm ever going to be able to work.
Poss favorite movie
inception.
Do you play any instruments? Uh, yeah.
I'll actually play piano and Trump burn
and get tall. What's more interesting?
Neuro Science. Physics early
because we can understand that
better at the moment.
That's present you've ever received.
When I was like I think nine or 10.
My parents actually gave me a computer
but they sat it in the middle of the
carto and I didn't even realize
it until I go to the room.
What is something you do to relax?
Uh,
best thing is usually television
shows or movies with friends.
What is something surprising about you?
I am probably one of the pickiest eaters
you'll ever meet and chicken nuggets
and frozen coker are basically my life.
You prefer cats or dogs?
Horses.
What's the machine learning model
that doesn't get enough attention?
I think studying,
I think starting um,
with like the simplest baseline
models is the best way to go. Sir.
Just stick with multilayer
perceptron for the starting point,
what's your favorite
operating system? I got to say
Linux. Do you play any sports?
Not really. No. Most adventurous
thing you've ever done.
I'm a multiday hike through
the Australian outback
source. Do you use to stay up
to date and machine learning
please? Twitter again, like the people you
find there was this amazing programming
of choice for machines.
Hyphen. Favorite professor
did James, Karen from the
University of Sydney, Australia.
Why do you think programming is fun?
I think programming,
it enables you to do some completely
and utterly a tremendous things. Again,
you'd never be able to do yourself.
You can control a machine that can
run billions of calculations a second.
What's the most amazing thing
society? Because I don't see where the
end point is for it. Favorite? Yeah.
Chicken nuggets. Name one
person. You really admire?
One of my curve. Uh, my um,
colleagues. James Bradbury.
What was your first program?
Oh, sorry. First program.
It was a hello world app that literally
just read in my name and then spell it
out back at me.
Didn't you talk to on the phone?
Um, Brad and from, and video.
Where do you go
back home to Australia.
Would you live on Mars?
What is one thing you can't live without?
Unfortunately my laptop.
What is one skill you wish you had?
I honestly don't know.
What is the last thing you do before bed?
Okay,
so I actually play the same set of four
songs from a soundtrack every night from
Ender's game.
What texts editor do you use of them?
What open source library you
really high torch is beautiful.
What was the hard problem you recently,
so most recently, um, language modeling.
What's the meaning of life,
friends, family, and um,
I guess science.
Who is one offered you really like,
I love, um, Isaac Asimov. What
is one thing that excites me?
[inaudible] we're
getting back into space. Best
advice you've ever received. Um,
just go for it. Even if you have
no clue what you're actually doing.
What is one piece of you'd give yourself
10 years
less worried about making mistakes.
You spend more time on the
internet or real life and to not.
Well and truly do you spend,
do you have any pets?
Yes. If you count my
parents or it's three dogs,
one cat and three horses.
What's something you've
learned in the past month?
Difficult audio is in terms of actually
processing it with deep learning.
Do you like spicy food? No, not at all.
What is a movie that made you
cry? Uh, up the beginning of,
if you ran the world,
what is one live you'd enact in?
Oh, I'm going to try and stay away
from being too controversial. Um, a,
a very soft universal income.
Is the singularity near not
near enough to worry about yet.
Who is one person you looked up
to when you went to college? Um,
John.
Jonathan Comma fells.
Her basically taught me a good chunk
of the programming. I know her.
What deep learning library I touch.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is a learning resource you
would use to learn machine learning?
Uh, foster AI by Jeremy
Howard and Rachel Thomas.
What is one goal you have in the
next 10 years and the next 10 years?
I want us to be able to compose an
entire orchestra without having to think
about it. Favorite subject in
school when you were growing up? Oh,
a Latin.
If you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
Something to be said about iron man
for the fact that he had to develop
everything himself.
What's your spirit and Oh,
probably slough.
I'm kind of lazy.
What do you predict comes next
after the deep learning height?
Hopefully the deep blending her
a hype doesn't die down. But, um,
I think everything connected devices,
bitcoin or ethereum. Ethereum.
Did you delete your Facebook?
Nope. Google home or Amazon? Alexa,
neither.
I don't want anything listening to me.
You prefer supervised or
unsupervised learning? Unsupervised.
Favorite conference you've ever been to?
Uh,
probably nips last year.
Awesome. Steven. Well,
thanks for answering those questions.
Thanks man. All right. Have a good one.